so I've been working for CERN and at
CERN for the past 18 19 years now it's
never boring
the job is different every day it's
terrible you don't want to come here no
no no no I yeah I'm just selfish sure is
this the world's greatest place to work
you you know we wake up in the morning
you got these mountains in the
background that most people have never
heard of actually called the Jura
mountains but are actually quite famous
they're called they gave their name to
the Jurassic period that everybody has
heard of because a lot of fossils were
found up there of dinosaurs so here
you've got like prehistory from tens of
millions of years ago just on your
doorstep but then really on your
doorstep what we're doing here at CERN
is we're going back in time as far as
you can possibly go to nearly 14 billion
years you have this place a laboratory
that's got thousands of people who are
from all over the planet who are all
different one way or the other they're
all smarter than I am it's a little
annoying but it's great there's no
better environment to live in an
environment where people are smarter
than you and you surrounded by brilliant
people and they're all here on their own
accord because they want to be a part of
something they want to discover
something and so it's just it's just a
positive and outstanding atmosphere so
getting up in the morning and thinking
that you're going to make some
contribution to understanding what the
universe was like then why it's like it
is now and where it's going is you know
quite a motivator in itself so it's
never really boring you do something
different every day but I imagine when
you're around a lot of alpha people
competitive people the top people in the
world
what's Turner class is it being
surrounded by such competitive driven
people all the time I imagine it could
it could it could grind you into the
ground well just just those who don't
understand that I'm right okay there's
only ones I have a problem with actually
is it's the most important part of
science most important part of science
is the fact that you have all these
other people and an atlas Bay of 3,000
people we all have a chance to look at
an analysis each one and say there's a
problem with that you're not doing this
this or this in this each analysis each
bit of data each each paper that we put
out there in the world has survived this
and that means that it's true okay that
means that it's been peer-reviewed and
by the smartest people and and we do
disagree we do have fights and we argue
about whether we're doing this right and
with what we saw is what we're saying it
is it has to survive that that's
important indeed to the outside it may
seem as if we're just a bunch of
physicists sitting in an ivory tower and
all we do all day is think about things
and do stuff related to particle physics
that's really not the reality there's a
whole world outside that people are
exploring in music in theater and
everything you can possibly imagine ski
and of course just up on the mountains
so it we're normal people
now you have to be lucky I think I think
I was lucky I think that you know you
have to study hard and go into physics
but you know if you do go into physics
for example the chances are these days
one of the biggest fields is particle
physics and if you go into particle
physics this is the place a lot of my
colleagues I've seen them all around the
planet over the years we most of us have
ended up here one time or another
because this is really the biggest
laboratory for particle physics so my
route to CERN was a very traditional one
if you like so I did a my a-levels in UK
and including physics and maths a course
went on to do a BSC in physics Imperial
College in London and did a postgraduate
degree at Imperial College and then came
here as a fellow and then a staff member
so it's a very traditional way of doing
it but we we also take people as young
as 1516 for like a week's work
experience occasionally to follow a
physicist or an engineer around and get
their hands dirty and see what we really
do we have programs for older students
sort of 18 19 years old where they can
spend a couple of weeks here there are
also plenty of people who are engineers
or technicians who come over here and
and they're always looking for good
people so you can always apply for jobs
there and in addition there's a lot of
programs to bring interns and to bring
students there's a lot of even
undergraduate students who come here and
contribute for a short period of time
but generally people's first experiences
long-term will be after they've done a
couple of years of an undergraduate
degree
normally in physics but also computing
electronics and so on and then come here
as a summer student which is again
something I did as well and spend a
couple of months working on a real
research project so different ways of
getting here depends what you want to do
on a ship
you know across across the English
Channel or something and you're on
you're on the the home of the engines
constantly the Hadron color limiter and
in within that you've got the the inner
detector and the pipe itself so
literally it is deep within that is
where all where it's all going on where
it's all kicking off